poltergeist is nothing more than a devil
or a demon as far as we're concerned
people say this guy's going back into
the medieval ages there are no such
things as devils or demons
yes there are
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey it's us again at 13 o'clock yeah
and this is episode 38. yeah when we're
we got a good one we're going to do ed
and lorraine warren yes we are talking
about the warrens
the infamous ghost hunting warrens
infamous
they're not that infamous they're just
they're well they're famous in
paranormal circles
well i guess infamous or famous
depending on how you view them
i like ed and lorraine they're uh
they're an interesting pair we'll get it
we'll get into it i guess they're not a
parody more because ed said lorraine's
still alive though
passed away she's uh she's 90 now i
think damn
yeah she's getting up there okay well
let's uh
let's do a little bit of housekeeping
well first well first keep in and i do
this every week but i think i forgot to
do it at the beginning of last show but
i really i want to give another shout
out to project entertainment network
yeah who hosts the audio version of the
podcast thank you very much you guys you
guys are
doing an awesome job we're getting our
our downloads are really
getting up there and they say we're
probably going to get picked up by uh
what was it i
heard radio yeah we're supposed to be
getting we're going by i heart radio so
we'll see how that goes that would be
really rad if that happened so um so
yeah that's really cool and
unseen hands the audiobook is just
flying off shelves yes my new book and
it's so weird because it's it's really
weird how
my different books in the different
formats like how like the difference in
the sales you know like some of the
books for some reason like sell better
in print form some sell better in ebook
form
yeah this one seems to be like the
audiobooks
like selling a lot of audiobooks yeah
the mammoth mountain case
sells very little audio books not
many ebook but a lot of print but a lot
of we don't know why
we're not really sure why it has
something to the way things are listed i
guess so
because we had to fix the thing on
audible and i think once we get that
ironed out i think that ebook will do in
fact do we have any free copies of the
audiobook for
mammoth mountain uh yeah i think i do
have a few copies okay if anybody wants
a free copy of that
it's the audiobook of the audio of
mammoth mountain we'll see we did a show
about it a while back too yeah because
we need a review it's been up there
forever and i don't think and it's sold
copies
yeah but for some reason no one even
rated it or reviewed it yeah and it's
not really being sold alongside your
other books because they have
kind of like the it says jennifer
ashford yeah they have my legal name on
there instead of my author name which is
i mean that is my name but it's strange
though they're not really so it's almost
like it's being sold by a different
author
but we talked to them they said they're
gonna they said they're gonna fix it
because i can't fix it at my end
right but uh so you know hopefully
they'll get that so we need we need
somebody to uh review that for us
it's only an hour or something long you
guys will like it yeah whoever gets it
yeah it's short
what else do we have we have another
channel coming
i think you guys are going to like this
yeah it's going to be a while but this
we'll we'll do like a little hint
of it yeah it's going to be called 13
o'clock in minutes yeah it's going to be
it's going to be
like okay we're going to use it almost
kind of like
an advertisement for the podcast and for
um books and things like that
but each it'll almost kind of like some
of them will almost be kind of like a
list video
yeah but it'll be really cool the way it
looks i've already seen samples of
websites but similar kind of
um similar kind of subject matter yeah
these are regular shows
each one will be you know it's for kind
of the new the younger add type crowd
you know what i mean
it doesn't want to sit there we
understand that i think each video
probably will max out about 10 minutes
no longer
yeah i don't want them to be any longer
than that and they'll be information
packed
and they're really good looking uh the
the graphics jenny has yeah i've been
working on graphics for him
it's gonna have good music in the back a
lot of good graphics and uh
for now it's gonna be text i don't think
i don't think we're gonna do voiceover
yeah we're debating whether we should do
voiceover or not it's like i'm bleeding
toward not because it's easier right for
me not to do voiceovers i don't have to
match up the graphics with the voiceover
design
right and a lot of there's a lot of
other channels that are like this one
that we're making that get
millions of hits one of them one of the
videos that we looked at got 32 million
36 million 36 million hits yeah and it's
going to be something along that line
along those lines but actually a lot
better what what they're doing
jenny and i can do that a lot better
well i just wanted to be cooler looking
yeah right like i like the look of a
couple of them but then
i don't know like i feel like i could
make it look kind of cooler and i don't
know maybe you could tell they're not
done they're not done by a real graphic
designer
yes you should leave that [ __ ] to the
professionals you guys like me
look and sound really slick it's going
to have really cool background music
and it's going to cover some really cool
cases interesting topics you guys you'll
see
we're going to use that as kind of like
a uh a promotional medium
for uh 13 o'clock for the main show
this will probably be a few months
before i get them put up because i want
to have
you know several videos i actually don't
think it'll take that long it might not
but i'm just saying
a few weeks you'll probably see the
first batch yeah
oh yeah i would think because we have
new hardware coming too
for that yeah anyway uh this
this uh is there anything else i don't
think so
okay let's get to the awards all right
so we're going to talk about ed and
lorraine more and now anybody who
knows anything about paranormal anything
yeah i mean
almost probably anyone who's listening
to this program now would probably know
who ed and lorraine
warren are now these two are probably
i mean at least in this country are
probably the most famous paranormal
investigators
yeah ever and if you're in your 30s or
your 40s or even your 50s
you grew up watching and lorraine yeah
because they've been on tv a lot and
actually lorraine is still on tv
quite a bit she's on some of the ghost
hunter type yeah she's been she's turned
up on some of the ghost hunter shows
she's on a haunting and paranormal
witness and [ __ ] like that sometimes
she's on there
because like i said ed died yeah several
years ago but she's she's still going
yeah
go ahead so these two they're kind of
like they're they're catholics
roman catholics yeah they're and they're
like really they're both from
connecticut
yeah and they have been they actually
formed what is called the new england
society for psychical research or
whatever it is for psychic research
rather
and that's actually the oldest ghost
hunting group in new england
yeah so they established that in the 50s
like 1952. yeah so they were kind of
ahead of the curve on this one i got i
got to give them that
now really they're i guess they're only
the only thing on their resume that
would like suit them to this
now uh what's up lorraine lorraine
claims that she's a clairvoyant and
sensitive and whatnot and ed is a
self-taught demonology is this
self-taught demon knowledge i don't
think he didn't go to theology school or
not
not that i could discover no uh he was
in the navy and he was a cop
i think when he a cop uh no i don't i
don't remember that i don't think he was
a cop i think he was just in the navy
weren't he
yeah well no i think he was a former was
he okay yeah i'll tell you one thing you
know
if you maybe if you grew up in the
united states
you see ed warren and lorraine warren
you pretty much know what it is you're
dealing with
maybe if you're from europe or another
country you might not culturally be able
to kind of understand what kind of
people these are that you're dealing
with it's
their their generation and the way they
were
if you ever see you ever see the program
aren't you bunker
yeah and all in the family all of the
family yeah
ed was kind of like an archie bunker but
a paranormal version of it now he was
funny
okay he was funny but he was kind of an
urban
irish american kind of a tough guy
background
yeah and he threw his weight around uh
you can see him in the videos he's
he's entertaining but he's just being
[Music]
being kind of a thug you know that's
kind of thug
a little bit like here's the thing
here's the thing
um i don't like i don't like to [ __ ] on
old people or anything like that and i
i genuinely do not think that
ed and lorraine warren ever set out to
defraud anyone on purpose
i think they were good people or yeah or
that they're trying to hurt anyone or
anything like that i really don't think
that i really do believe
that they believe in their what they're
saying
in their demons and all that i really do
think they believe in it yeah
and i really do think that they
genuinely think they're helping people
yeah this is very religious based yeah
very religious based thinking and it's
kind of a magical thinking type process
yeah very folklorish a lot of things
that they say
not really scientific and not really
backed up with logic or reason
right not to say that they were uh
uh charlatans the charlatan
does things they know yeah they're
bullshitting you right
that implies that they're doing it yeah
deliberately
i don't really think they were i don't
think that's what the situation was
now they were motivated by money edwards
of course we can get into that later
yeah but that's but i really think that
they thought they were helping yeah i
mean i definitely do
think that they were trying to maximize
profit sure
sure yeah um but in a way i don't think
um from everything i've heard like all
the families that they um
you know that they investigated or they
helped out or whatever now i don't think
they charged them anything
other than travel expenses no but
everything that the
the warrens did usually it was done
uh in order to either write a book
be on a tv program or possibly get some
kind of a movie deal
everything was kind of a pt bar let's
put on a show
yeah and they would barge into other
people's investigations and try to
hijack
an investigation yeah and bring in their
own film crews and trying to get as much
raw material as they could so they can
maximize my eyes on it later because hey
this
this paid for their house yeah you know
because that's really i mean
the bulk of their money does not come
from the quote unquote investigation
process it comes
selling it comes from selling their
books yeah from selling from going on
lecture tours and selling their lecture
series
now here's an interesting thing when we
were um you know we've been reading a
lot about the warrens and about you know
all the movies that were made about
their cases and stuff
and we were watching some old interviews
with them from like back in the 80s and
early 90s
and it's interesting to note that a lot
of their interviews
and they used to do like a show which
was kind of hosted by
tony sparrow who i think is their uh
son-in-law
yeah so they would do shows with him now
on youtube you can only find like the
first six or seven minutes of the
interviews
and then you have to go to another site
to like buy
buy the show the rest of the show and
you know i must admit
i was tempted to buy something because
were you really because man they're
funny
i'm not really buying what i'm hearing
yeah yeah
but i wanted to hear what they had to
say you know it was i was looking at it
in terms of just entertainment
now i also let's just start off by
saying
cases that the warrens were involved in
it's not automatic
that's a hoax i don't think that they
hoaxed a lot of those cases
right all right some of the cases that
they were involved in at least
slightly involved in and sometimes i
think we're real cases
other things that they were involved in
if it was just them involved in it i
kind of think maybe it was something not
there
maybe something minor and of course that
can blow it into it
into a case because that was in their
advantage
uh to me to have big cases on a regular
yeah on a regular basis and uh
i tell you what they were really good at
it they had a constant stream of
paranormal material let's just say it's
paranormal now they claim to have
investigated between 8 and 10 000
cases yeah and they have been involved
or acclaimed to have been involved
with many very very high profile
paranormal cases including amityville
and things of that nature yeah well they
now
track them they would track them down a
lot of the times you know they'd hear
about something going on somewhere and
they'd show right up and then try and
try to take over the case yeah even
though and a lot of times too i think
they
exaggerated their involvement yeah
to a great degree like with anfield yeah
that definitely did happen in enfield
and stuff like that
but um what i was oh what i was gonna
say when we were watching like parts of
those uh
interviews and stuff like that with ed
lorraine i think they were from 1991
1991 or something like that and uh
something i noticed about
now lorraine warren seems like a very
nice lady yeah i like her clothes
she's got the she's very old yes she's
got the religious
she's got the religious clothes with all
the with all the like yeah the lacy
collars and stuff that's crazy
but yeah she had a she has a very
distinct uh fashion sense and in case
you didn't know
the the little dwarf woman from
poltergeist was based
actually on yeah that's right that's
right zelda rubenstein i think played
her yeah her character is based on
that's yeah that's based on lorraine
warren except uh shorter obviously yeah
but um
but the thing about it is a [ __ ]
better yeah yeah
well she well she was a lot more
entertaining yeah little zelda
rubenstein yeah
she was but um she's dead too and she
that's that yeah she does
oh well but um so oh what i wanted to
say was that
something that i noticed like lorraine
seems like a very nice lady
ed not so much not a nice lady
he's not he seems like not really a nice
guy he seems kind of
like a jerk like she like here's the
thing like he would
start you know talking and ranting and
mansplaining or whatever he was doing
and then lorraine would interject
something
like oh well there was this thing where
blah blah blah like she would say
something related and then he'd be like
he'd have the attitude like well don't
interrupt me don't it wrong like well um
why can't i tell it or why and i'm like
dude well they didn't like be upstaged
back off you know the uh ed was from
a macho time yeah he was a navy guy and
you know from his generation you know
and he had
irish guy irish city guys and italian
city guys were trying to outdo each
other a lot in those days yeah
each other and uh you know reflected you
know it was
his generation was a macho generation so
sometimes a
macho guys like that might overreach a
little bit they might overreach because
it seemed like every single one of those
interview snippets we saw
there was something where she would try
to say something and he'd be he didn't
tell her to shut up
yeah but he'd just be like well why
can't i tell it or that's not how it
happened or he would be like that
yeah yeah he'd be like real short i'd be
like man she put up with that because
they were married a long time yeah we
don't know what's going on behind the
scenes though she probably kept his ass
in line
maybe yeah and i must say too that i
think i developed because before i was
just kind of like oh frauds whatever
but i developed a lot more um kind of
sympathy or empathy for her like
remember we watched part of that
interview yesterday where she was
talking about how her and ed met
yeah and she was talking about like the
recording and then she talked about him
going off to the navy
and he was in like a really bad um
accident like he a ship he was on
collided with another ship
she thought he was lost at sea and most
of the guys died yeah
and he actually did rescue a dude like
he he put a dude on his back
and like swam in the freezing north
atlantic oh yeah he wouldn't have saved
this guy's life
ed wasn't a fake tough guy no he wasn't
he really was a tough guy yeah
and so i so i thought that was kind of
sweet like the way she was talking about
him and she was like
because she thought he was dead and he
was flipping out and i was just kind of
like oh
i can't be mad at somebody after they
tell the story like that
you know i i have
kind of a weird uh mixture of uh respect
and loathing for the warrens in a
certain way i respect yeah
i respect that i would agree that they
that they worked hard and they brought a
lot of paranormal material to light
they entertained a lot of people and
they brought the paranormal
into the main on to mainstream
television i got i got to [ __ ]
give them credit to that and really what
i don't like about them though is that
i'm not real sure about the honesty all
the time yeah because they
hyped things up and they parroted a lot
of mis
paranormal misconceptions and they
parroted lots of
folk tales over and over about yeah
now if for you know our regular audience
they know that you know
i've lived with paranormal occurrences
you know off and on throughout my life
and
you've seen them yeah i believe in the
paranormal because i've witnessed it and
so is my family
but the paranormal is not common it's
it's rare
and uh this whole thing about
investigating ten thousand
ghost cases within a human lifetime i
gotta call [ __ ]
yeah i don't know there's just i don't
think there's that many that would be
like
that would be like witnessing ten
thousand airplane crashes in your
lifetime
yeah it's just they're not there's not
enough that's a very good analogy
yeah yeah ten thousand lightning strikes
and you're like that's like a boast that
the north korean supreme leader would
make
[Laughter]
i've seen i've investigated every single
ghost
kim jong-il has investigated every ghost
in the planet
and defeated the giant sea monsters with
his fists yeah
watch our sea monster show from last
year
but yeah so i kind of feel the same way
about them it's like look i don't
begrudge the people
trying to make a living okay because
that's that's what i'm doing you know
i write books we have a podcast you know
yeah it's funny it's people that buy
uh jenny's book if you see when the
related thing is the related connections
the people that buy your book also buy
it also by the warranty
which is funny because mine are like
more from a skeptical perspective
yeah i think a little bit more well
yours are a little more even-handed and
level-headed
yeah you when the evidence isn't good
you say the evidence isn't good
if you don't if you if you think
something's suspect you say it's suspect
yeah which yeah and i i will definitely
like most of the time uh
you know if when i was writing like when
i was writing the new one the unseen
hand it's like i'm willing to take most
people
at face value it's like if a bunch of
different people saw this particular
thing i'm like okay but i'll say that
but if one person saw this thing and it
sounded really stupid
yeah and it was just kind of out there
and they didn't have any other
yeah they didn't have any other evidence
backing up yeah i'll say this person
said they saw that right whether i buy
it or not uh i don't think
and everybody's looking for evidence and
in this paranormal stuff you're never
really going to find hard evidence
because it's usually based upon witness
testimony most of it yeah because it
happens so fast yeah
and it doesn't happen under controlled
scientific conditions so yeah this could
be witness testimony and that's all
we're going to be able to deal with is
testimony
and the thing too like amazing little
things like i have a little piece of
paper with the blood on it and i have
yeah
photographs but you know i just if we
were to get that blood
uh tested dna test i sure would want to
know whose blood that is
yeah that would be i'm kind of curious
to find out it was one of ours but we
couldn't find any
places where we were bleeding i don't
even know if that would be enough blood
to
test though they could probably do it
yeah okay i'll just get back let's go
back to the warrants
but so the warrens now like i said ed
died um a while back
now lorraine warren is still alive now
they've they um
started an occult museum quote unquote
yeah which is
in the back of their house yeah and this
thing's probably worth a minute the ebay
value has got to be in the millions
it's got to be like all the stuff
they've collected over the years because
they're it's like full of like stuff
they say is possessed that they've
taken away from people's houses because
you can sell a different box for if you
can sell a dipping box for 300
that little haunted doll that they have
is probably worth three grand damn it i
wish i
thought of that about that that was
genius and all the little ghost photos
that they had and
everything that they've collected you
know over all the years and all the
cases just for the sheer novelty of it
i would think that some paranormal
connect collectors would love to get
their hands on that
oh yeah the warren museum well i'm sure
after she dies i don't know if she has
it like bequeathed to someone or not
because i mean all her
a lot of her um kids and and even her
nephew john zappas he's like a big
paranormal investigator too he's quite
famous
um as well so i'm imagining they'll
probably get it or they'll keep running
it or whatever
but um yeah and if you check out the
videos that they make actually you know
from what i saw i'd actually recommend
them i'd buy something like that
yeah just to see it well see probably
okay and
probably the most famous thing that's in
their occult museum is
annabelle yeah that's the doll i was
talking about yeah the haunted doll it's
a raggedy ann doll
and they actually made a movie and
here's the thing probably i think maybe
a lot of younger people nowadays if they
know who ed and lorraine warren are
it's because of the conjuring right the
conjuring 2 and annabelle which are all
like
interrelated movies yeah now because
they're the main characters of this now
this
is kind of where i have a beef okay
the original movie the conjuring which
was a very which is a good movie it's a
good movie
but it's told from the perspective of ed
and lorraine warren right so they're
kind of like the main characters and
it's this haunt it's this uh you know
haunted house and they're investigating
it and blah blah
now it's based upon a true quote-unquote
true story
the haunting of the parent family okay
and it's based on andrea perrin's book
her memoirs of growing up in this
farmhouse
it's called house of darkness house of
light and we actually we listened to
um a really long interview with her yes
it was like a three hour interview
where she was talking about um the movie
and was talking about the differences
between what really happened and what
was in the movie and stuff like that
and um obviously now she says first of
all
she said she liked the movie very much
she's like you know we lived in the
house for 10 years and all the stuff i
mean the book that she wrote about is
three volumes so it's like not a short
little
whatever and she's like you know the
warrens were the main
character in the movie and that's fine
you know that's how they did it and
stuff like that she's like and the
warrens did
go there they did investigate it and
stuff like that she's like and i don't
have any like
um she didn't really have any animosity
toward them
but she said you know she said in the
movie
it made it look like they kind of like
moved in with us and they were there for
a long time and stuff like that she's
like but you gotta understand that
they were probably only came there like
five or six times over like the course
of a year
you know she's like they weren't there
constantly they weren't you know
and she said another thing in the movie
she said they did an
exorcism and she's like and that didn't
really happen
she's like now what did happen and this
this was a good story like i kind of
really like this
but she said this is what happened she's
like they had a seance
okay and she's like she was just little
her and her sisters but they were like
sitting on the stairs watching
what happened during the seance
allegedly is
that um the the warrens
okay now it should be noted too that the
warrens turned up uninvited
the parent family did not call them
specifically
getting back to what i was saying before
right to come to our house and help us
out with this haunting that we have
she says they heard about it through
someone else
and turned up right there that was the
that was the m.o yeah and she said um
andrea said that she's like my father
was
livid she's like she did not want he did
not want these people here
he kind of believed there was a haunting
but he i think he just it sounded like
he just kind of wanted to sweep it under
the rug and he just didn't want to blow
it off
yeah he just wouldn't want to pay
attention to it and so he didn't want
these like
people coming and stuff so but
apparently the warrens came to do this
seance
and they show up at the door and it's
like
two cars it's like an entourage they
brought like a whole crew like they
brought a psychic and a camera guy and
all these other people right
and andrea said she's like my dad was
really mad and all this other stuff so
they have the sound she's like it wasn't
an exorcism it was just like a seance
they were trying to talk to
whatever and they were trying to get uh
the psychic to manifest the whatever was
haunting the house or whatnot
and she says now she says that her
mother
got kind of possessed and then like her
mother like
flew loose was like thrown across the
room like in the chair
and was knocked out and stuff like that
now this is great
because okay so andrea says her dad
tries to run
to his wife to like figure out like to
see if she's okay
yeah and ed grabbed ed warren and
grabbed the dad's arm
to keep him from going yeah and she says
and andrea says my dad
clocked him right in the face knocked it
out and knocked dead out
and then went to see what was the matter
with his wife yeah there are a lot of
there's a lot of stories
there are a lot of stories about ed you
know
getting into fights or you know yeah he
just seems like
very like he was he had a strong
willpower and strong ego i'm sure that
you know to ed ed's you know
he's on his mission you know kind of
like a preacher in a certain way he's
got a
yeah you know he's going to have to
spread the word but in his case it's
paranormal so he's got to get there he's
probably going to call it an active
investigation
yeah and his version of an active
investigation is hunting down where the
ghost
cases are and taking over yeah you know
like a g
[Laughter]
i love it yeah but and i do think so i
do think that i don't
think that he ever perceived himself as
an obnoxious jerk no i think he thought
he was
i think he thought yeah i think he
thought of himself like kind of like a
superhero
yeah like i'm a demonologist you have
demons i'm going to help you whether you
want me to or not yeah and he was not
really aware of anything outside of his
own kind of
uh folklorish concepts of demonology
yeah he didn't know anything about
parapsychology and he didn't know
anything about psychology
no he didn't even know what sleep
paralysis was yeah you might want to
talk about that
yeah we we actually um there's actually
a really good
uh skeptical breakdown like two skeptics
this is from 1997. uh but two skeptics
perry d'angelis and steven novella uh
who's a doctor
they actually went to um
the occult museum and kind of explored
all their stuff and
interviewed ed and lorraine and stuff
like that and they
noted that now they said the same thing
we said they said
they seem like very nice people they
seem genuine sincere they don't really
they're like we don't think they're
deliberately trying to hurt anyone or
defraud anyone or anything like that
because like they don't really
understand how the scientific method
works
right they don't and when they um you
know when ed was talking about
uh the smurl case which we might talk
about a little bit after the break
um where jack smearl said you know he
would wake up and there would be like a
like a succubus or whatever like raping
him or like on top of him or whatever
and the skeptics were like well are you
aware that sleep paralysis is a pretty
common thing where you wake up and you
think someone's on top of you you feel
a presence in the room and you can't
move and ed warren did not seem to be
aware of that
rather common yeah uh thing that happens
and i mean
a lot i've had it happen once you know
it's it's scary
and i knew what it was so it's you know
ed's generation wasn't into that kind of
stuff yeah
more into straight up supernatural yeah
yeah this was spiritual
warfare it involved gods and demons and
unknown forces and
and and i've seen paranormal i don't
think is what it is
i think it's more in the realm of
natural physics
yeah it's quantum physics and i mean i
think for instance if you went up to if
you went up to ed warren and started
talking about
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis he
would what's that you know
yeah he wouldn't be down with that right
and he said well sometimes you know
it's a mind over matter thing where in
certain altered states of consciousness
you know the human mind can kind of
hijack reality you know and make some
and
ed would not be the kind of guy that
that would be open minded to that oh
you can no no you can't do that well the
thing about eleanor
nuts and bolts yeah yeah materialism
this no
yeah no insult meant to them but yeah
they seem very um
sheltered like they're they were retro
yeah they're
they're upbringing was very sheltered
very religious they both came from
very very very religious families and so
i feel like that's kind of all they know
right and i think ed warren is even
stated as like
straight up saying yeah that you can't
understand his work unless you're a
believer
like you know if you're an atheist or if
you're a scientist or whatever then
there's no way you don't have faith and
you can't understand what he's doing
even though what they're doing i think
is very would would be considered
extremely old school by today's standard
yeah it was they were a productive
couple they did get some interesting
cases out there
to to to the to the media yeah and uh
they kind of were kind of made the
blueprint of a lot of the
the ghost hunting types yeah they're
like the og ghost hunters yeah if they
were a rock band you're talking about
what led zeppelin yeah they're like the
led zeppelin
of of the paranormal war
and on that hilarious analogy
you know i thought you were going to
make it like ghosty lyrics at that time
i can't come up with lyrics that fast
you can't i've heard you do it okay
just in the shower yeah he sings in the
shower all the time it's very funny
but anyway okay so we're coming up to
the halfway point so when we get back i
kind of wanted to talk about
more of their cases and yeah let's get
to some specifics
okay i think we we painted a general
picture of
who the warren's art it's funny because
we're paying a picture to a crowd that
knows who the warrens are but yeah
it's all fun and games like i said it's
like our usual show we just kind of like
you're hanging out with us we're
drinking coffee and i'm vaping and
jenny's vaping
we're bullshitting about the warrants
yeah that's all that's all it is
all right okay so we'll be back in just
a couple of minutes
the necrocastic yarn the podcast
that blends horror and heavy metal
properties with a common connection
brought to you by hosts token charm
clock
[Music]
featuring interviews and more with the
stars of madeleine
the negro casta con mondays on project
entertainment network
subculture corsets and clothing is our
favorite store for unusual clothing
shoes and accessories
they offer a wide selection of men's and
women's clothing at great prices
subculture also offers a cool selection
of shoes and accessories
steampunk gothic apparel retro corsets
and so much more at subculture corsets
and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculturecorsets.com
that's subculturecorsets.com make sure
you use the discount code
thirteen o'clock for a ten percent
discount subculture corsets dot com
or visit their store in jacksonville
florida just off i-95
it was a time when we raced to the tv
guide to see what was playing on monster
movie matinee that saturday afternoon
and in some cities that evening it was
all about werewolves vampires giant
lizards
and those great japanese monster movies
relive it all every week as jim adams
and mark maddox bring you
monster attack monster attack takes a
look at those classic
monster movies that we all grew up
loving join us every week on monster
attack
exclusively on the project entertainment
[Music]
network
[Music]
all right we're back yeah talking about
the led zeppelin of course
the led zeppelin of the paranormal world
i think that's kind of
you know it's either i would say led
zeppelin right yeah you
i guess so vanilla fudge
where did that come from that's even
further back i know i was gonna say
that the okay
okay so anyway so i i talked a little
bit about
the first conjuring yeah because that's
probably like i said that's probably
when
they came to a lot of prominence to the
newer generation because that movie was
such a big hit
now they also made the conjuring ii
now the conjuring two was very loosely
based on the enfield poltergeist case
yeah good movie but not close to the
cape not really yeah
and well and the same thing about the
conjuring it's like the the movies were
good
yeah but based on a true story that's
a little sketchy and i really didn't
like how they their treatment
of of um the dynamic between guy line
playfair
and morris gross well that was in the
bbc one oh that was the bbc one that was
good and i
retract that yeah he's like never i'm so
old i can't keep them all straight i
know all those reboots of all those
movies
those newfangled movies those moving
pictures
yes i remember back i remember back when
movies look like they were all made for
tv
yeah like go watch the amityville horror
now the original it looks like a
made for tv special i thought you were
going to say that you remembered when
movies were just made out of flip
daguerreotypes
i'm younger than you and i know that
it's a character oh my god for real i
have to
i'm not adam okay this is the you're not
educated
i have to say this you guys this is so
funny speaking about getting old this is
kind of off the topic but it's
speaking about getting old okay so this
past saturday night
we were out at independent bar like our
regular hangout and we were hanging out
with the dudes from a star tonight who
are like really awesome
really really awesome like wave they're
from miami
and they came up because they were at
the theme park so they came out and hung
out of the club with us
and so i know that they're younger than
us i know that
yeah but i forget because they're like
super into 80s music and stuff like that
so it's easy to forget that they're
you know yeah so me and tom were joking
and you made a joke about richard burton
i don't remember what we were talking
about some men can drive drunk
some guys can play guitar drunk but
richard burton could
act drunk yeah he could drunk act he
could he could drive drunk acting yeah
because you could obviously see
in some of those movies that [ __ ] is lit
oh yeah
and i was lit when i was telling that
story it wasn't very funny
they just started busting up laughing
yeah so we made a joke about richard
barton right yeah richard
so so michael goes who's the lead singer
he says to me
i don't know who richard burton is i was
born in 1993.
yeah and i yeah right and i just
i i put my hand over my mouth and i just
stared at him yeah and he laughed
yeah and i was like do you know what
year i graduated high school
1990 i was like you could be my kid yeah
i know that's weird and he's like yeah
but you're rad says that's fine is like
we're like they're peers
they go to us for fashion advice i know
it's like so funny they're so awesome
you guys need to go listen to them
they're
they're really cool if you if you're
like into like um the cure or joy
division
or yeah yeah even if you like like
interpol something like that
they're really good they're really good
yeah i'll put a link to them yeah
you should on the on the youtube you
should i'll put a picture of the
pictures of them up
yeah they'll be yeah who michael is
they'll think that's awesome
but yeah so i was like so you know i'm
old i know what a daguerreotype is
but uh before my time though so anyway
okay so the conjuring ii
was basically it's not like yeah they've
enfield case they bbc made that
three-part mini-series too
but that didn't have that didn't have
the warrants in it but here's why now
the conjuring 2
was supposedly based on enfield which we
did a whole show on so i'm not going to
go too much into that but the here's the
thing
the since the conjuring one had ed and
lorraine warren as main characters
this one did too problem with that
is that according to guy lion playfair
the guy who wrote the book this house is
haunted
that was about the enfield haunting and
he was there
with maurice gross and all of them for
not
it was like for most of the haunting i
mean it was an 18 month
yeah period i mean he was there for most
of that time now according to him
the warrens showed up uninvited quote
unquote
one day yeah said the whole thing was a
hoax and
left yeah one of the biggest parrot one
of the biggest poltergeist cases
of all times yeah the best the best
recorded best best documented
all the cop the police witnesses just
everything they said it was a hoax
then they'd go to a weak case and then
uh
but here's the thing that seems really
weird to me because that seems like
the world's kind of like i think it was
player hate it might have been they
didn't have that case so they had to
debunk it they had they
said no they were maybe that's what and
it was in a different country and stuff
like that too so maybe they yeah maybe
they were going with your british
poltergeist
yeah yeah yeah yeah but well here's the
thing that even if they had
like said that it was legit then they
wouldn't say it was poltergeist it says
demons because they said
everything was dana's everything
everything is you even made
that meme i made a meme of the warrens
that said i'm not saying it's demons but
it's
demons i'm gonna have to find that it's
running on my computer somewhere i guess
i could
but it's demons because everything is
demons and even sometimes they'll even
say oh well there's ghosts and blah blah
and there's demons and also there's a
demon right and the demons are like
suppressing the ghost or the demons or
like whatever
so yeah so the whole thing about the
conjuring too it's a good movie
i mean as a piece of entertainment i
guess i didn't see that one i enjoyed
the bbc one yeah was close to
well see okay the bbc one and i think i
mentioned this on the show about the
enfield
maybe i don't remember if i did or not
but um you know the three-part
mini-series
it was really good like it had a lot of
really good actors in it like timothy's
fall who i love
he was in it and all this other stuff
but it seemed like the first two parts
were really good like they kept it kind
of restrained and then the third part
just went flying off the rails it just
it didn't have anything to do with it
now we can go back and here's another
one that just came to mind we can go
back to the amityville case
yes the amityville case uh
it's a bad case it's it's very weak just
because the genesis of the case
involving lawyers and involving
horror writers and guys convicted of
murder
that that case was just no good and
probably
and it doesn't fit any known pattern of
anything i mean it's not vultures
it's not yeah it's not not really an
interactive haunting is it possession
what is it to me it's just
it's a bunch of crap well it seems like
a mishmash because but
because it is a mishmash lauren's got
involved in it what about 20 days after
20 days after the lutz's left right and
then they come up with one of the
most famous photos of the case which is
at the hallway the little boy looking
around the corner right i gotta call
[ __ ]
that is obviously a fake product yeah
and that that's a little bit well i
don't think it's fake it's a
it's a boy in a room it's just a person
yeah and that was taking
just the warrants and their camera crew
no one else there no other witnesses
yeah now i should note i don't think
here's what happened like the warrens
after the lutz's left because uh
famously they were only there for 28
days and then they got the [ __ ] out
yeah um you know like i said we did a
show about amieuvil 2 where we called it
a hoax because i think most people think
it is oaks and i mean you know
most people normal people do so i guess
i i'm not sure who called the warren
let's put it this way
the case as presented in the movie and
the book is a hoax
yeah maybe something happened there but
only the family would know and that's
not the case we're given
right when we talk about the amateur
build we're talking about the movie and
the book
yeah yeah and the stuff that the lutz
would say the lutzes would say in the uh
okay you can take the lutz's account
over the radio
you know then they do radio interviews
yeah what they're saying that happened
you there were no witnesses too so you
couldn't prove it one way or the other
but i would tend to think that no that
that case
well and the thing is that a lot of
things they they're very vague
yeah when they're doing a a an interview
really big and the thing is a lot of
things they said can could be
uh disproven after the fact like
remember how they said oh the front door
was blown off his hinges oh we called
the cops
the records showed that they did not and
they you know they also had that thing
where oh we saw hoof prints in the snow
there was no snow
on that day where they said they saw
that yeah and all this other stuff so a
lot of their stuff is kind of
yeah sketchy but now i'm not sure who
called in the warrens to the amityville
case they
they came the ones
so like a local news crew so maybe what
happened was
the news wanted to do like a story about
it
so they got these two to come i would
think that ed
wanted to cover the case he goes down
there and gets a local
goes to the local news saying we're
going to put on a big show here
yeah you can have a really good story
come with us we're going to go to a
haunted house
yeah that's probably what happened
because
if if i was trying to make a living the
way ed was made trying to make a living
that's what i would have done and i was
like i'm a trained
direct salesman yeah i'll go to your
house and try to sell you something back
in the day
they have the internet now does but
anyway that's what he was doing he's
going like
and they're going to document my
investigation right
all right as impartial witnesses
supposedly which they
i guess they were yeah you know but
that's what that's that's yeah
he was a they were shameless self
promoters
that's what you do you go right next to
it come on let's go let's go
i can't really like i find that i can't
really fault them for that too much
because
that was like i said that was the hustle
you know tell us how you did business
back then yeah and if that's how you're
making a living then you know fair
enough
and that was the hustle of the day
that's how you you know
when i say hustle that kind of sounds
lowly and cheap but we're just having
fun here you know
that's how business was kind of the
conducted yeah that's that's how the
paranormal was handled in those days
in the united states yeah so i don't
know if they were doing anything
different
they were just better at it yeah they
were good at it but
they could they could tell a good story
and put it into a framework
that the average american could kind of
like emotionally buy into because it was
religious based
yeah you know and in those days you know
the church was stronger
and yeah and it should be noted too that
there were plenty of people who had
hauntings or
possessions or whatever they thought
they had that did legitimately
call the warrens for help yeah and there
are lots of people who said that the
warrens helped them that like the stuff
went away
after they left now also i should note
that the camera the uh the case that the
conjuring was based on the parent
haunting she said that it got worse
after their intervention yeah okay but
uh she's on record of saying that
but um she didn't really like i said she
didn't have any animosity toward them
necessarily she just said well they
exaggerated their involvement and stuff
like that now
another case that was act that was very
famous that uh the warrens were involved
in was the snedeker
yes or snedeker how do you pronounce
their name man that's a good story
and that was based on uh well that was
the movie the haunting in connecticut it
was based on their story and there was
also now they were on was it a haunting
or
they're on board or both they're all
both and so i tell you the haunt the
version that was told on the haunting
yeah that series was awesome i love that
version
it was a good that was a good episode
that one really had me intrigued because
i'd forgotten about that case
yeah because i've i've seen the
snedekers like on uh remember the old
daytime talk shows like yeah that's
right one thing i'm sorry
they were on sally jesse raphael right
right there and that was just
fascinated you know that i had a
political guys experience when i was a
kid so i was well it must be
boy it must get really bad you know yeah
so i really didn't really pick through
that case you know
yeah i didn't you know i wasn't really
trained you know i just
at that point i you know pretty young i
just had my own personal experiences but
i hadn't
read any parasite parapsychology books
or
you know so i just kind of took it at
face value and i was like wow that
really blew me away
and then when i saw it on haunting i
thought that was a really interesting
fascinating case but now that i know
more about
it well okay the thing
about their case yeah
is that sold in a lot of different ways
okay now here's
this is the one in case you don't
remember this in the decker case like i
said it was uh the haunted uh
hunting in connecticut was based on it
and it was kind of a pretty loose
interpretation i saw the movie a while
back
but um this is the one where they were
the where the son had cancer
he had hodgkin's lymphoma and they moved
to this house to be closer to the
hospital
and uh the house they moved into used to
be a funeral home
and down in the basement there was still
stuff like left from the funeral home
yeah yeah um and stuff like that now the
problem
with this is that
the accounts of the family
are not are inconsistent yeah it seems
like in some interviews
uh carmen snedeker she i think she has a
different name now because i think she
remarried but um
because she's still around she actually
is a spiritual advisor or something now
but i can't remember what her new last
name is but um
in some interviews she said we didn't
know
it was a funeral home before we moved in
now the landlord calls [ __ ] on that
because he said everyone knew it was a
funeral home i told them it was a
funeral home
and you know so and all this other stuff
now and also
she says in some interviews i didn't see
any paranormal activity until
later right and for a while she thought
her son was just hallucinating it
because she even asked the doctor
evidently
like if the cancer drugs he was on could
cause hallucinations or cause these
personality changes or something like
that
um because it seemed to affect him the
most right
and then other times she said oh i was
mopping the floor
and the bucket filled with blood or you
know things like that like she saw
things
one of the things i remember is that you
know i had seen them on a couple of
different programs this is in the early
days
yeah and on one of them i think it's
like on the second or third time they
appeared on television i don't remember
if it's like maury povich's show
or maybe sally jesse if i've been roy
povich i think
about half of the audience was up in
arms against
the the snyders and it turns out they
were the neighbors
[ __ ] on them that that didn't happen
and some of them were kind of like the
nosy neighbors you know with the
they had some woman she stands up she's
got like a pen a
pen and paper and she's checking stuff
off on june 23rd
and all that kind of damn yeah yeah
she's cute it was just
ridiculous yeah it's on youtube and i
remember
i remember that when i saw that at the
time i'm gonna what the hell is going on
why is the whole neighborhood up in arms
about these people you know these poor
people you know
yeah but looking at it now they mad they
were i think
they're kind of full of [ __ ] now ed
warren
was talking to somebody who was writing
a book about it i think
or yes analysis you might know the the
yeah well how did that go
and just told me okay yeah here's the
thing this is and this is actually
that's good because this is the next
point i was going to make
now the movie the haunting in
connecticut is mostly based on a book
called in a dark place
a story of a true haunting or something
like that it was written by a horror
writer named ray garton
now ray garton has gone on record as
saying that the stories that he got from
all the family members over time and all
the different families were inconsistent
and it was very difficult for him to
write the book he said the family was
going through a lot of problems
alcoholism drug addiction things like
that he's like they couldn't keep their
story straight i got different stories
from different people
and it was very hard for me to put them
together now he says
he has gone on record as saying that ed
warren told him point blank
the family is crazy just write what you
want and make it scary
yeah so they were just trying to make a
scary book and not really trying to make
anything
that was true to what really happened or
anything like which kind of takes me
back
to my my opinion of the warrants this
mostly has to do with ed okay
and lorraine warren work basically kind
of like religious fundamentalists
and in religions people will tend to
kind of toe the party line
they'll tell little white lies to keep
faith built up
would be a good way to put it jenny like
you know you
kind of uh if you ever go to church if
you have a religious background i guess
when i was young you know when i was
young i was in a
you know yeah you probably know more
about that because i was not racist
sometimes religious people will tell
little white lies to keep people
believing in
the religion yeah that's a good way to
put it yeah i think the warrens kind of
did the same thing but about the
paranormal
yeah they might have an interesting case
going on maybe there's something to it
but it's not
quite as good as they want it to be
or it doesn't quite support the
religious narrative that they want
so they'll lie a little bit push
to flavor the case the way they want
that case flavor yeah
doesn't necessarily mean that that case
didn't happen yeah it just means that
that case didn't really happen the way
that the way that they wanted it they
wanted it to happen they didn't really
tell you exactly what happened
and in some cases the case wasn't there
but they're going to let the they're
going to lie and say that case was there
to help support the other ones yeah i'm
talking about yeah this is another one
we're going to this isn't a real case
but we're going to
blow this into a real case and add it to
the wood pile because you know what
that proves that god is real and how is
that wrong
right that's the kind that's what i was
gonna say i don't think that
they would consider it lying or
sinning because lying is supposedly
helping people because they're
because they're they think they're
establishing a greater good
right they're bringing more people into
god into the faith
so it can't be bad right exactly so i
think that's
yeah that's a good way thank you for
helping me i have a sometimes hard time
you know no you were doing good you were
doing struggles
yeah but that i think that's what
they're doing so like i said that's
that's what we mean when we say i don't
think they're doing anything like to
deliberately defraud people or
deliberate deliberately
hurt people you know not in their mind
um i think they think that they're
justified right now
um i want to mention too
like a couple other cases they worked on
there was the the smurl case which
actually i'm surprised they haven't made
a big budget movie they made a
made-for-tv movie in
1991 that was just called the haunted
yeah it's funny and it has the guy that
played dale
in the walking dead you guys it was in
it getting getting raped by a pig
or a succubus i gotta see that what's
funny is that all these old cases have
matured
into legend and now that they're making
movies out of them yeah it's ridiculous
it's fine
the funny thing about the smirl case
like i didn't you know i don't really
have time to go hugely into it and stuff
like that maybe we can do a whole show
on it one day because it's kind of
interesting i read about it in my book
the unseen hand i wrote about it in
there a section of it but um
an interesting thing about it is that
the all the all the ghost raping that
took place
in it like some of it was done by a
succubus who looked like a hag kind of
yeah but also
some of it was done by a pig creature
yeah which is weird because
you know jody jody from amityville
horror also a pig creature what's with
the pig
pigs walking around the tv it was 70s is
that a
singer was that a 70s i think it had to
do with deliverance and squeal like a
pig
you think maybe i don't know i wondered
if it was some kind of
i wondered if it was some kind of
satanic thing or maybe it was even a
throwback to maybe lord of the flies i
don't know
the pig head you know that was all just
kind of mushed in together into the 70s
mindset
yeah maybe there was just a whole like
good game
pigs and satan and homosexual rape and
the devil
yeah it all goes together
oh i should note too that uh
pig rape if that's the only thing you
take away from this
yeah name of this episode is pig rape
i'm a sexual pig
[ __ ] like back in the day back in the
day there was a seven people
a walking pig it's a two-legged pig it's
not like an actual pig
it's a person like george's luck's
stepson what was his name one that did a
little thing
daniel i think it was something like
that he said that when he looked up in
the amityville case and he looked up and
he saw the pig in the window
yeah and the window he said he said look
like a cartoon pig with a
wolf's teeth and a big old smile looking
down at him yeah like a cartoon
yeah that's right he did say that didn't
he look like a cartoon pig yeah
oh and it should be noted too that's a
freaky it's a freaky idea
it is now didn't george let's say he saw
that too because here's the thing and
they actually put this in the movie and
here's the thing
in the movie the amityville horror you
can actually see
jody up in the window when he's when uh
when uh george
is coming back from the boat but you
have to like slow it down it's like real
subtle
yeah like you guys yeah i didn't really
notice it at the time until i saw it in
hd
but um now he says daniel says that him
and george were they were outside
and they looked up in the window and saw
the pig okay in missy's window
and then but when they went up to the
room
she was asleep and all that was going on
was the rocking chair in her room is
rocking by itself
so they didn't actually like see it they
saw it just up in the window yeah that's
what they said anyway
so pig creature i don't know yeah but
speaking of uh
man-like creatures i just wanted to
mention ed and lorraine warren have also
written a book called werewolf
oh yeah and it's about an actual
werewolf you guys
supposedly god i forgot about that yes
an actual where
ed investigated a werewolf case yeah
yeah and uh
that it's like i probably don't have
time to go into it but it was a guy
named bill ramsey
and uh supposedly he was wigging out and
the police arrested him and stuff and
they sent him to a mental hospital and
they said there's nothing wrong with him
and blah blah
but the uh the warren said that he grew
teeth and
ears and [ __ ] like that and then he was
a werewolf and they wrote a whole book
about it so you know
you can look that up if you want to and
then and it was kind of like the
american
van helsing yeah i'm sure that's how he
styled himself
although he wasn't as skinny as the van
helsing i know ed well which one peter
cushing peter coaching
oh my god mister no mister no back teeth
himself
missed peter cushing where's that i know
i want those cheekbones
i know i want those cheekbones god i'd
like to look like that when i'm all
decided
he was so rad looking oh and also i want
to mention this too before the end of
the show because we only have a couple
minutes left
this is also fascinating too and this i
didn't write about the werewolf in my
book because werewolves is kind of out
of my uh baileywick
but uh i did write about this case and
it's uh it's usually referred to as the
devil made me do it case and the warrens
were also involved
in this uh it was the trial of arnie
cheyenne johnson
now this story at least the first part
of it
uh was actually on a haunting also i
think it was on the episode called where
demons dwell the one about the well
yeah that was a good episode and the
little 11 year old boy that saw the band
and he got possessed and
that was the old school of haunting yeah
i think it was the first or second
season
that fur those first two seasons were
awesome yeah after that started to go
downhill
but if you saw that episode that was
actually based on a real case
and um what ended up happening later
was that the quote unquote demon that
supposedly possessed the little boy and
they got it out of the boy
but it went into uh the br the little
boy's sister's boyfriend or fiance arnie
cheyenne johnson
now allegedly this demon got inside him
and years later arnie cheyenne johnson
stabbed his landlord to death alan bono
was i think the landlord's name
and when he went to trial
the warrens testified on his behalf that
he was possessed by a demon
as far as i know this is the only case
in american jurisprudence where somebody
actually
tried to say not guilty by reason of
demon possession
did it work no no but the warrants
the warrants showed up on campus they
showed up okay and they said yes he's
totally possessed by a demon we knew
this was going to happen because i think
they had been involved
even like when the 11 year old kid now
it should be noted too
that when the kid grew up okay now let
me start this out
when the kid grew up i think him and his
brother sued
the warrens because they said you know
you made us look bad there was no demon
blah blah blah
but arnie cheyenne johnson and uh the
the kids older sister who
later married they said no it all
happened just the way we said
okay so you know but the warrens did get
sued i don't know if they won or not
right not
but um arnie cheyenne johnson he
actually um
the the demon possession thing didn't
work yeah but because of the
circumstances surrounding the murder
yeah
what ended up happening he ended up
stabbing the guy because the guy
his landlord was drunk and it actually
snatched up his
niece or something uh who was nine years
old
and he was trying to get the guy to let
her go right and he wouldn't he was
being all belligerent
right and um so they got in a fight and
he stabbed him so
he just got manslaughtered okay because
he said it was kind of self-defense i
think he only did a couple years or
maybe five years or something like that
but like i said the demon possession
[ __ ] didn't work out because you know
the judge was like you can't prove that
whatever
right but that's as far as i know it's
the only time that the the warrens have
gone on record in the church why would
you want to sue the warrants the
warrants never struck me as rich
um i think they made a living but i
don't think they ever got rich well i
think they sued them later because
of uh emotional distress and because
they they painted
um david glatzel what could you get from
them they weren't millionaires well you
know i know right but you know
why does anybody sue anybody they were
they were bad they pissed off right but
like i said i don't know if they wanted
it
but uh [ __ ] there was a we could go on
all day about this but
yeah we're already pretty much yeah yeah
we're kind of at the end of the show so
i guess you know if you want to hear any
more about the warrens there's we could
always revisit the warrants there should
yeah because they have like lots more
cases that we could talk about
and i didn't even really i wanted to get
into the werewolf thing but i'm sure
they'll come up
we should do a show about werewolves now
that i think about it i don't know
i'm just kidding i'm tired we don't do a
[ __ ]
werewolf all right like a werewolf was
nothing more than just a medieval
misunderstanding of a
serial killer you find a person a woman
dead and she's
partially nod on now
nowadays that's a serial killer back in
those days oh my god a human couldn't do
that
there was a man who turned into a wolf
and that's because the romans had
stories like or like florida man that
guy that
ate off that other guy's face yeah
because they said he was on bath salts
that wasn't why though although i don't
think they ever determined why that
happened yeah
just a crazy dude i didn't talk about it
anymore there's a zombie you guys why
were they naked down in
in see that's what's so intriguing it's
florida and they were bombs
they bumps i think so yeah i'd have to
revisit that because i remember hearing
about it at the time it was just like
weird gay bum sex
going on with bad salts in the middle of
traffic but see i think they did
but i think they did drug tests on that
guy and he wasn't bad self i don't think
is there a drug test for bath salts oh i
don't know
what i just heard that it wasn't that it
wasn't drunk but it is bath salts i've
never really had a good explanation of
what it is
i don't know some people call it flakka
there's some really cool videos that
people have taken it
there are some very funny robots that
look like broken robots yeah you'd have
to be a [ __ ] to want to take that
maybe it feels really good when you take
it but you just look really stupid i'm
just looking at it i'm just looking
go on youtube and go look at flakka
f-l-o-k-a flocka
you tell me if you want to do flocka
like i said maybe it feels really
awesome to you it's just you just look
dumb to other people
it's not working maybe it's one of those
things okay so anyway uh so we're
getting to the end of the show so i
guess we'll uh wrap it all up
so uh once again going to give a thank
you to project entertainment network who
hosts our audio podcast um you guys are
rad
and uh go check out all of their other
podcasts they have many
and uh spanning many different subjects
yeah and also
um keep all right keep your eye out
you're right keep your eye out for our
new channel coming soon yeah it'll it'll
be out uh pretty soon and also
um if you want to check out some of my
books you may do so
um i still have some free audio book
codes for
some of my other books so um if you want
one of those
if yeah contact me if you want one of
the free audio books um
i have a bunch still for unseen hand
that i have a couple for some of my
older books too
but you have to say that you're going to
write a review you have to write a
review because that's the whole point of
me giving them yeah and what's funny is
that
we you only have five reviews on the
audiobooks they're all five stars
the audiobooks are flying off yeah
flying off the shelves the ebook of the
same book you just only sold like two
e-books
and it's because there isn't any reviews
yeah would somebody please but
buy that damn e-book and review it come
on
yeah yeah yeah i think it's only six
dollars once it gets the first review
they start selling
yeah yeah it's like six dollars yeah
yeah so if one of you would do that
that'd be cool
i don't think we can't give this away
for you yeah that's
yeah that's only the audiobooks that i
get for that and the person that buys
the audiobook off of the amazon
actually they can't write the review on
amazon i'm not really sure how that
works
it goes on audible yeah okay weird they
used to transfer over but i don't know
if they don't
it'll eventually happen another deal
okay so uh i think that's all
we have for today and uh see you guys
next tuesday for another [ __ ]
session yes
[Music]
[Applause]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you